la gráfica de puntos muestra el número
de horas al día que manejan los
conductores de los autobuses de 14
escuelas cada punto representa un
conductor entonces por ejemplo aquí nos
está diciendo que hay un conductor que
conduce una hora al día dos conductores
conducen dos horas al día y por aquí nos
dicen que hay un conductor que conduce
tres horas al día y bueno al parecer hay
cinco conductores que conducen siete
horas al día y pensemos cuál de las
siguientes opciones es la estimación más
cercana al rango percentil del conductor
que maneja seis horas al día nos dan
varias opciones y tenemos que pensar
cuál de estos percentiles es la
estimación más cercana al rango
percentil del conductor que maneja seis
horas al día
así es que ponle pausa al vídeo e
intenta averiguar cuál de estos
percentiles es la estimación más cercana
del rango percentil de un conductor que
maneja seis horas al día por su
estoy observando la información que nos
da esta tabla bueno voy a suponer que ya
intentaste resolver este ejercicio y
ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos ahora
cuando estamos hablando acerca de los
percentiles un percentil en realidad
podemos referirnos a esto con dos
significados distintos uno es el
porcentaje de los datos que están abajo
de la cantidad en cuestión la otra
opción es el porcentaje de los datos que
son iguales a la cantidad en cuestión o
están debajo de ella así es que vamos a
empezar preguntándonos cuántos datos
están por debajo de las seis horas al
día primero nos vamos a preguntar cuál
es el porcentaje de datos que están
debajo de las seis horas por día vamos a
empezar contando los 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 así
es que siete de los catorce están por
debajo de las seis horas al día por lo
que se utiliza
a esta definición del percentil tenemos
7 sobre 14 ok este es el porcentaje de
los datos que están debajo de las 6
horas al día y 7 entre 14 es el 50% así
es que si utilizamos esta definición lo
que esto nos está diciendo es que seis
horas al día está en el percentil 50
pero si nosotros quisiéramos usar esta
otra definición en la cual incluimos los
datos que son iguales a la cantidad en
cuestión entonces también tendríamos que
incluir a este dato y entonces tenemos 8
de 14 lo cual es igual a 4 entre 7 si lo
queremos escribir como un porcentaje nos
conviene escribirlo en su forma decimal
entonces ponemos por aquí 4.000 y
estamos dividiendo a 4 entre 7 por aquí
está el punto decimal 7 cabe 0 veces en
el 40
cada vez cinco veces dentro de cuarenta
porque siete por cinco es 35 y entonces
de residuo nos queda 5 y bajamos este 0
50 y luego 7 por 7 es 49 49 y sobra 1
bajamos del 0 el 7 cabe una vez pero
vamos a redondear a los primeros dos
decimales entonces nos queda que el
porcentaje el 57
estamos en el rango percentil 57 así es
que cualquiera de estas dos respuestas
sería una respuesta correcta si no
tomamos en cuenta a los datos que están
en la cantidad en cuestión los
conductores que manejan seis horas al
día se encuentran en el rango percentil
50 pero si tomamos en cuenta los datos
que si son iguales a la cantidad en
cuestión además de todos los que están
debajo de ella entonces los conductores
que manejan seis horas al día se
encuentran en el rango percentil 57
pero si nos fijamos en las opciones
sobre las cuales tenemos que escoger
aquí si tenemos el percentil 57 y no el
percentil 50 lo cual nos dice que las
personas que diseñaron este ejercicio
utilizaron la segunda definición en la
cual para calcular el rango percentil de
seis horas de manejo al día nos
preguntamos por cuál es el porcentaje de
los datos que son iguales o están por
debajo de seis horas de manejo al día y
listo